[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
big announcement
it's Tuesday
[Music]
oh I hope he does it
runs he's gonna say some crazy [ __ ]
right
I mean we might as well dial the crazy
up to like 500 here why not let's just
dial the crazy all the way the [ __ ] up
I mean
he's gonna be very upset he is very
upset that that Trump 2.0
the vacuum lady Carrie Lake scary Lake
lost in Arizona
and the right wing is [ __ ] mad oh
they're [ __ ] mad
losing their [ __ ] the Maga tears are
delicious though aren't they
they taste so good in coffee
ah
marketeers really do taste good they are
delicious
you should dry them on like cake or
something I'm telling you it makes
everything better these we got cheated
oh they were counting votes they were
still counting votes I've heard a lot of
video out there this morning of [ __ ]
right wing Talking Heads on the internet
talking about hell oh the Democrats the
Democrats only they stopped counting
when the stone the Count's only ahead
for them Carrie Lake hasn't really been
ahead this entire time they've been
counting and by the [ __ ] way this is
Arizona that we're talking about here
the reason why it takes so [ __ ] long
to count in Arizona is because
Republicans in the state of Arizona
have had control of that election system
the states decide where you're going to
vote how many polling stations there are
the Dropbox situation early voting
mail-in absentee you dumb [ __ ]
really need to pluck your head out of
your ass and understand that the reason
why the State of Arizona
takes so [ __ ] long the count not just
this year but we remember in 2020.
is because a republican rule in that
state
there's a [ __ ] Republican legislator
Republican governors
the [ __ ] Maricopa County Board of
Elections supervisor is a God damn
Republican you stupid [ __ ]
Cary lake is a kook she's a [ __ ] kook
and she she was carbon copying Donald
Trump
full stop
you put a [ __ ] oversized suit in a
red tie on her and dye her hair up a
little different maybe give her a little
different camera filter you got Trump
in Drag
I'm telling you this is [ __ ] crazy
ass [ __ ] that these people are bitching
this morning
that it took so long to count
and Katie Hobbs she's she's a secretary
of state she didn't recuse herself
no Secretary of States don't recuse
themselves when there isn't an issue
there was no issue counting this none
none there has not been an issue there
is literally cameras in every single
[ __ ] Counting Room
there are [ __ ] Watchers in every
single [ __ ] Counting Room they
haven't encountered one problem I mean
other than the [ __ ] they're making up
the [ __ ] they're making up the only
[ __ ] injunction they've filed was to
extend voting hours
by three hours and the judge said no
that those people had plenty of time to
vote
this is really [ __ ] dumb
that we even have to go through this
nonsense but their Q anoners
it's all a conspiracy theory
I read on the internet Facebook said my
Uncle Earl posted an article from fake
Gabe you should see this [ __ ] article
fake game posted oh my God it says
there's six thousand meals this time not
2 000. oh my God the next decision is
gonna have a heyday
some dumb [ __ ]
but they're gonna run with it
the best part about the whole [ __ ]
State thing where they're like oh this
was stolen and yeah that the founding
fathers and the federal government and
Joe Biden
this is a governor's race in a state
you states rights [ __ ] need to
make up your minds
the states have the authority over those
races yes they have Federal boundaries
that they have to abide by in an
election
but there's a state constitution
and this was a race for governor of that
state
you are you people really are [ __ ]
ridiculous on the right
I don't know what happened to you guys
you used to yell and scream about
deficits and taxes
and now you're like the state shouldn't
have the right to change how they count
I want State tracks the state should be
able to tell women no it's the federal
government I mean you can't even [ __ ]
decide you can't decide anything
we we want we want no one to vote but we
want people who vote for us to vote
oh my God I can't believe white people
had to stand in line to vote
holy [ __ ] they're counting votes
well we should still count more votes
because Carey Lake's got more votes so
keep counting but don't count but keep
counting it's really stupid [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ]
the problem is
the real problem
is that people listen to these
[ __ ]
they listen to these [ __ ] and
that's how they got mine [ __ ]
their mind [ __ ] into believing all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] that's even
contradicting itself
and you know we we continue to try to
figure out why but who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ]
really in this point we know now from
this election
in a midterm in a midterm the turnout
folks we won the Senate and we're
probably going to be Senate plus one
that's [ __ ] huge
I know it doesn't feel like that's
[ __ ] huge in a midterm like this
when they tried to make it about the
economy
we are probably going to be on the verge
of maybe just maybe Democrats holding by
one seat it doesn't look likely or the
Republicans holding by one or two seat
in the house
one or two seat is not a [ __ ]
majority in the house
218 to 217 holy [ __ ] one person sneezes
and they can't get [ __ ] done
let alone yesterday Marjorie Taylor
green tucked-tailed and run on her
[ __ ] she wasn't gonna vote for Kevin
McCarthy because when she got in a room
and people explained to her how the
[ __ ] house were she's been there for
two [ __ ] years and she doesn't
know how the house works
do you know why Nancy Pelosi is not
sweating do you know why
because she [ __ ] understands better
than anyone how the house works and she
understands that if the Republicans only
have a one or two vote Advantage they
really don't have an advantage they may
not even get the [ __ ] speaker they
want
Nancy Pelosi knows she she could pull
over a handful of Republicans to vote
for their speaker
a minor Republican or even a moderate
Democrat
hell you could make Liz Cheney the
Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi knows all this
that's why she's not freaking the [ __ ]
out that's why Democrats aren't freaking
the [ __ ] out
we had Rachel bittickoff run yesterday
and she explained it well
best case scenario we still have speaker
Pelosi because Democrats pulled out with
one goddamn vote 218 to 217. best gay
scenario worst case scenario is these
[ __ ] chuckleheads
get what they want they put Kevin
McCarthy who is a [ __ ] [ __ ] box
and a dumb [ __ ] in charge and he starts
selecting people for chairman of
committees and they can't stop talking
about Hunter Biden's laptop
and that's their message we we know what
now election denial and [ __ ] talking
about crazy Q Anon conspiracy theories
where it puts you what position
politically it puts you in
they lost Big Time mastriano Carey Lake
Tudor Dixon they lost their asses
the Secretary of State the the Q Anon
Secretary of State nominees they lost
their ass and Herschel Walker is gonna
go down in flames here he's [ __ ]
there's no way the Democrats aren't
going to turn out in Georgia
and when Donald Trump announces whatever
the [ __ ] he's gonna announce tonight he
better [ __ ] run he better [ __ ] run
he better not disappoint me
I want that [ __ ] to run
now that we have the election results in
and we know
in 2024 they can't steal the [ __ ]
election in Arizona they can't steal it
in Pennsylvania they can't steal it in
Wisconsin they can't steal into Michigan
those are the four states they wanted
and they wanted Arizona more than any
other state I've been I was saying that
for the last two weeks in the lead-up to
the election
they had Steve Bannon [ __ ] Dinesh
D'Souza all kinds of Q and honors out in
Arizona trying to push them over the
line and it only made them lose
Steve Bannon did not help votes in
Arizona
if anything he caused more people to go
ah this Katie Hobbs can't be that
goddamn bad
so Trump announcing Trump announcing in
this point and this when they had the
biggest [ __ ] smack in the face that
they could possibly have for 2024 folks
[ __ ] the house [ __ ] the Senate these
Secretary of State and governors races
are more important to 2024 than any of
that
those are the most important races and
they didn't win [ __ ] one of them
not [ __ ] one
and it's because they were trump-backed
Q Anon election denying fools Kooks just
crazy [ __ ] kooky loony sons of
[ __ ]
that's why
you can point the finger wherever you
want
but it was basically fake Gabe's little
chat running for office holy [ __ ]
Katie Hobbs didn't even have to debate
Carrie Lake some people thought it was a
mistake and really honestly at this
point I don't think anyone should have
debated any of these election deniers
and we should going forward we shouldn't
Democrats in this country should not
debate if the Republicans put a election
denier
as their candidate you should not debate
them
they do not believe in democracy there's
no reason to Katie Hobbs has proven that
that you do not have to debate these
[ __ ] to win
their craziness alone will make them
lose
and all you have to do is participate
and engage in democracy because that's
what Democrats did in Arizona they
leaned into it they worked hard they
knocked [ __ ] doors they got the
ground game they didn't rely on Carrie
Lake's Instagram and Twitter page and
her [ __ ] bigotry
to win oh she's a she's a TV anchor
it'll be great yeah how'd that work out
for you dummies
I hope they keep going though I hope
they keep going
everyone wants the Republican party to
turn here away from Trump and turn back
to normal what the [ __ ] is normal with
these people
and even when we get to a different
state how are we going to know if that's
[ __ ] normal
is much off the deep end as these
[ __ ] have gone [ __ ] them let
them let them fight it out themselves we
do not
we do not have to participate in the
fight I'll tell you what we are gonna do
though
we're going to stand back and we're
gonna mock them we're going to stand
back and we're to point out how all of
them are the same they're all Kerry Lake
every [ __ ] last one of them is Kerry
Lake all the way down to Mitch McConnell
and Kevin McCarthy
they're all the [ __ ] same they'll
capitulate just watch when Trump runs
watch if he announces tonight they're
all gonna [ __ ] it they're all gonna
capitulate to him this idea that somehow
this isn't [ __ ] Trump that trumpism's
gone is stupid
it's alive and well and a small
percentage in this country they're
[ __ ] mind [ __ ] they can't stop
that's why Carrie Lake lost she couldn't
help herself she just couldn't do it
she literally stood in front of cameras
and said I'm gonna be your worst [ __ ]
nightmare for eight years she said those
words into a [ __ ] camera
and expected to win
on what [ __ ] planet do they live
this is insane [ __ ]
and Wendy Rogers there's a video of
Wendy Rogers I don't know if you know
who Wendy Rogers is you think Carrie
Lake's a [ __ ] nut job holy [ __ ]
Wendy Rogers is like hold my [ __ ]
beer I'll show you [ __ ] real kind of
crazy
she's a goddamn Nut Job
even she says yesterday and I believe
it's on Charlie Kirk show we'll try to
pull that video up when we get Texas
Pawn Gabon
but even she says on one of these
[ __ ] Trader TV news networks or
whatever the [ __ ] it is that they're
running over there
she says maybe we were in an echo
chamber no [ __ ] Sherlock
how in the [ __ ] did you people know this
there was no evidence of what you were
saying none other than Dinesh d'souza's
[ __ ] fraudulent [ __ ] documentary
and book that people are sitting in jail
in Texas for because they won't admit
that they're [ __ ] lying
that was your best evidence is a movie
from Dinesh D'Souza holy [ __ ]
you're you you are the echo chamber
Wendy Rogers
you are it
and it's so [ __ ] small now the
problem is is you're you you're so
[ __ ] loud and so goddamn stupid that
it bleeds out into other [ __ ] stupid
people
who want to believe this garbage
we have a weird electorate in this
country it's [ __ ] weird
because they're not very well educated
on what our government is and how it
functions they're not even the people
who claimably political pundits on the
right don't know that the [ __ ] race
that Kerry Lake lost is a state race
under the state constitution they're
talking about founding fathers and [ __ ]
Arizona was not a [ __ ] State I hate
to [ __ ] break it to you it was not a
state when the founding fathers were
sitting around creating ideas you stupid
[ __ ]
and it really is [ __ ] weird that you
States right people are mad that the
State of Arizona ran their election the
way they want to run their elections it
really is [ __ ] nuts
but that's what we're dealing with is
the electorate in this country is
ignorant
of what our system actually is they're
[ __ ] dumb
they just don't understand it
but they still vote I'll give you an
example
this is a prime example here in Missouri
my home state we had a referendum on the
ballot
to make recreational marijuana
legal now it's medically legal here in
the state right now so you have to get a
prescription to go get marijuana
as of January I believe you won't have
to do that anymore
some people were not enthused about the
licensing of the places that would sell
marijuana and grow marijuana but it
passed anyways because people don't want
marijuana to be [ __ ] illegal are on
schedule one they don't want it the
majority of the country just like they
don't want people getting their hands on
weapons of war it's it's a popular
[ __ ] idea
but here in Missouri it passed
overwhelmingly to legalize recreational
marijuana marijuana
past overwhelming just like in any other
[ __ ] state it would
this state still elected overwhelmingly
a United States senator who is right now
the Attorney General of the state who is
vehemently
anti-marijuana [ __ ] gonna go to
the United States Senate and he's going
to vote against what they voted for on
the referendum
if he had the chance
it's not it's not because
they believe two things at once it's
because they're [ __ ] ignorant
they do not understand how it works they
see marijuana legal woohoo and they're
like ah but I'm a Republican
no you're not
that's the problem is they don't know
they're not Republicans
these people that you see at these Trump
rallies
with these [ __ ] shirts on saying this
crazy [ __ ] about Michael Jackson and
[ __ ] JFK Jr they're not Republicans
they're not conservatives
I almost bet you go line by line and you
say do you want to go broke because of a
medical bill they'll say [ __ ] no
do you want a decent [ __ ] wage hell
yeah I do do you want to make sure that
your children start school and your
grandchildren start school at three
instead of five hell yeah that would
help out a lot they'd get more educated
and and we wouldn't have to pay [ __ ]
daycare
for two extra years
do you want people to go broke get a
college education hell no
do you want to make sure that your
Social Security and your Medicare are
there and secured for you when you need
it yeah God damn right I do I earned it
I pay it every week on my paycheck
you think those are Conservative
Republican ideas they're not
these people have been mind [ __ ]
they're deluded
they're ignorant of how our system works
and people like fake Gabe
sending out links on the chat
and your Uncle Earl on Facebook
have really done a number on these
people's reality because they're not
Tethered to it anymore
the good news is here's the good news
and I had high confidence in this I said
it for weeks and weeks and weeks I was
listening to Lawrence O'Donnell last
night and he was saying there was only
two people that said that Democrats
would win bull [ __ ] [ __ ] I've been
saying it for months months and months
and months I've been saying Democrats
would [ __ ] win and democracy would
come out on top here [ __ ] months
I never [ __ ] and you know this
audience I never said well maybe just
maybe maybe no
I was highly confident that if you if
you the people engaged in your democracy
that it would come out on top because
that is what happens
when you when you participate in
democracy you get democracy when you
participate in autocracy that's what you
get
it's not hard to understand these things
but they don't
and that's why that's why the right wing
is having a lot of trouble this morning
with this carry Lake loss they just
don't get it they just don't get that
their ideas [ __ ] suck no one wants to
talk about bathrooms
no one gives a [ __ ] what [ __ ]
bathroom someone's going in no one gives
a [ __ ] who loves who and who wants to
marry who they don't give a [ __ ] as long
as you're not telling them who the [ __ ]
they can love and who the [ __ ] they can
marry
people don't want to hear about your
Christian Church ass [ __ ] where you're
trying to make us be [ __ ] Christian
even if you are a Christian they don't
want to [ __ ] hear that nonsense
they definitely do not want their
sisters their mothers and their
daughters
and their wives
to get their [ __ ] rights taken away
from them especially when their life
could depend on it you [ __ ]
these are not hard things to understand
their ideas
[ __ ] suck
they are horrible
did you hear one [ __ ] time
Carrie Lake ever talk about deficits not
a goddamn not not once
not [ __ ] once
and I'm not saying the Republican Party
should stand around talking about
deficits
because honestly this whole election
denying stuff and this Q Anon stuff
Democrats are going to win bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger as we go
along here especially as gen Z that
voting block gets bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger bigger
and the baby boomer voting block gets
smaller and smaller and smaller and
smaller and smaller
so keep going if that's what you want to
do but just realize if you [ __ ] don't
pluck your head out of your ass and the
right wing doesn't realize where they've
lost their way it's them it's them
they've lost it's them
the Nazis it's them that's why they're
losing
then good luck to you
and I hope that tonight
whatever his announcement is we all know
what the [ __ ] it is
hey I'm gonna get indicted and I don't
want to be indicted and I think this is
going to help it's not going to help but
I think it's going to help and I I
definitely want to whine and cry and I
want to be a little [ __ ]
and I want everyone to feel sorry for me
and I want to continue to have stupid
[ __ ] rallies
so that my ego feels good so I can do
the uh jacking off draft dance
to the YMCA that's what he wants to do
I encourage it
[ __ ] yeah let's do that you know what I
actually I here's the thing I want
Merrick Garland to now wait to indict
this [ __ ] till next summer
I want him to wait till next summer to
indict this [ __ ]
I might as well gather up evidence you
know he's going to keep on [ __ ]
climbing he ain't gonna stop doing that
he ain't gonna stop committing crime
but while the Republican party is down
[ __ ] kick him and let them [ __ ]
let them kick themselves [ __ ] them
there's no way you can convince me a
Donald Trump running not running or just
saying anything
saying anything
is good for the Republicans and at this
point in our history anything that is
bad for the Republicans and bad for the
Republican party is good for democracy
foreign
that's where we're at folks
when you have the Q anoner's in charge
of their party which
even Marjorie Taylor Green is having to
take a step back to make sure that Kevin
McCarthy is the speaker because if they
don't
she just figured this out the other day
if they don't they could have a speaker
that they don't want
that's because Q anon's got a hold of
him well let it get a hold of him [ __ ]
them
they don't understand how the [ __ ] works
the people that these [ __ ] idiots
elected don't get how it works they
don't understand it they just don't know
that's why Herschel Walker is gonna
[ __ ] lose that's why Dr Oz [ __ ]
lost that's why Blake Masters [ __ ]
lost
Bone Heads
and they're not gonna stop being
boneheads
they're just not
and to think that it's going to be a bad
thing for democracy for The Biggest
Loser of all time
the biggest [ __ ] loser of all time
Donald Trump to announce that he's gonna
run if that's bad [ __ ] no that's not bad
for our democracy it's obvious that [ __ ]
is good do it you little [ __ ]
you scared little [ __ ] [ __ ] Trump
run you [ __ ] run do it
do it
I dare you and you know the other thing
that you should do while you're
listening Trump not only run but you
should really drag these [ __ ]
through the mud I mean you're you're
really going easy on Mitch McConnell and
DeSantis right now in Camp you should
really lean into that you should really
lean in and get people to try to help
you bang these [ __ ] up and you
really should try to create a bigger
shark army than what you've got
you really should do that and you should
really use what power you have in the
Republican party to show the Republicans
that trumpism is not dead yet
and then it's here to stay you should
really do that trust me and you should
really lean into this whole election
denial thing I mean you should deny the
2020 you should deny the 2022 midterms
you should really deny all elections
everywhere and encourage people not to
vote especially people who like you
that's what you should do that's what
you that's what you're going to do
that's why it's good for our democracy
folks
Donald Trump can't help but self-implode
everything he touches turns the liquid
[ __ ] every [ __ ] thing turns to liquid
[ __ ]
all of it
so good for him run another campaigny
little [ __ ] let's do this everyone
stick around we're gonna be right back
with Texas Paul and my co-host Gabe
Sanchez right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[Music]
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we got Texas ball here with us my
question though to the audience is do
you think they'll be able to find the
Electoral College this time you think
you'll be able to find it they could
find it though in 2020. I wonder if
they'll be able to find it now Texas
ball what do you think do you think
they'll be able to find the Electoral
College storm storm the Arizona I'm not
sure exactly what they're wanting to do
here but they seem to be poised for
wanting
um an erection I mean Insurrection it's
just it's hilarious I'm telling you they
can't find the Electoral College they
can't find the clitoris they can't find
a goddamn thing because they're [ __ ]
Republicans man Republicans suck at
every aspect of life and that is just a
law of physics right right well I I
couldn't agree with you more and what do
you think about this take on on Carrie
Lakes
um you know the manga is freaking out
because they're freaking out over
Republican law that it was Voting law
that was set in place in Republican land
Arizona Democrats really haven't had a
stronghold in Arizona to to Really
um set election law for a long time the
other thing too that's [ __ ] hilarious
is they're pissed off about Maricopa
County more than they are about anything
else and the dude running the election
there is a [ __ ] Republican it is it
is insanity to me that these people
absolutely cannot understand they'll be
like oh he well he's a rhino he's a
Democrat get the [ __ ] out of here with
that nonsense
come on
you know I mean they're running this
election under the laws that [ __ ]
douchey put in place right
[ __ ] douchey of all people put these
[ __ ] laws in place and you're gonna
[ __ ] and whine about them well why are
they still counting votes because
[ __ ] douchey wouldn't let them
[ __ ] count votes when they came in he
made them hold them till the [ __ ]
election day before they could even
[ __ ] open the ballot okay because
you're [ __ ] Republicans you can't fun
run a [ __ ] thing including an
election so yeah that's why they're
still [ __ ] counting you [ __ ]
losers right well you know if if
arizonans are pissed off about how long
it takes their vote to be counted my
suggestion to arizonans because that's
the only ones that can change us anyone
outside Arizona you can [ __ ] and moan
all you want about how long it takes
Arizona to count but Arizona's are the
only one that can change this they can
actually tell the [ __ ] candidates hey
you either you either reform our voting
system to where we have results faster
or we will fire your dumb asses they
could say that they could use their vote
to do that but they haven't yet and
that's okay whatever that's how Arizona
counts California accounts
but but do you really think it's the
slow voting or you think it's really
just that they're [ __ ] coops they're
just [ __ ] kooky
[ __ ]
I think even crazy [ __ ]
Republicans looked at finchermen went
whoa laughs
why I mean oh my God
yeah and the look on Wendy's Roger I
love that video you put up man I love
that video you put up here so I hope you
put it up again that look on Wendy
Rogers [ __ ] face
oh yeah yeah maybe we maybe we were in
an echo chamber yeah
yeah
sure lock right maybe maybe they were in
an echo chamber Gabe Sanchez
um maybe they were maybe they what
what's your what's your uh board say
there Carrie what Carrie loser
oh my god did you see this video uh Gabe
Sanchez of uh Wendy ronders is talking
about being in an echo chamber did you
catch yeah I posted that video did you
post it oh okay oh that's that's right
you post that's how I saw it see I I
watched it because you were I think you
said like something about that's
delicious yes I said well that's most
delicious right when Wendy Rogers is
like huh were we in an echo chamber like
you are the echo chamber you idiot
you're not in it you are it you are it I
mean
oh no go on no go ahead I'm sorry oh I
was just gonna say the fact that you
know Charlie crew was like well that's
that's not the vibe we were getting on
the ground that's not what we were
hearing on the ground it's like yeah
because the people you only [ __ ] talk
to were the people who were just
offering confirmation bias to your own
position
I mean that's the problem with the
Republican party right they hear what
they want to hear and as soon as they
confirm their own bias they go see I
knew it it was exactly what I thought
and you're like that guy down the street
said that guy down the street with a
trump flag and he's reading on Facebook
all kinds of cute on stuff his name's
Gabe something or else boy he really
confirmed my bias
um speaking of confirming bias here
watch as this happens this is the video
clip that look at the look on his face
you mean this tiny little face on this
huge [ __ ] head
oh man okay so this is Charlie Kirk show
I guess is that right is that where you
found this yeah okay yeah all right this
is 25 seconds and it's the one of the
most beautiful 25 seconds you're gonna
see watch this [ __ ]
I'm shocked by some of these numbers
Wendy I gotta be honest I mean you know
the state really well you've been a
Grassroots activist for a while
the vibe on the ground
was totally different than this wasn't
it yes well we wonder now if we were in
an echo chamber
well I mean look I I don't know I just
beginning to get some perspective
I like how I don't know who the other
guy is is that is that Jack prostate
that's not Jack Frosty no no no that's
not Jack that's the guy who's been on on
Charlie's show the last week or two with
Carrie Lake drip all over it right yes
if he has a non-partisan type opinion or
something it's the the fact
anytime well recently they've had these
moments where they're like well that's
not what we thought it was going to turn
out to be like what's going on you know
they're like [ __ ] showing up
Christmas Day and learning that Santa
Claus isn't real or some [ __ ] they're
like oh my God are you telling me
there's no [ __ ] Tooth Fairy you sons
of [ __ ] they're the guy down the
street told me the Tooth Fairy was real
you [ __ ] it's really stupid
stuff isn't it and the [ __ ] hilarious
part is is if you watch his face while
she's saying that and if you can see
Charlie Kirk's face I saw another video
where it was backed out where you can
see Charlie Kirk's Faith the amount of
Agony in their face was incredible
because they're the [ __ ] Echo chamber
she's living in right they are the
[ __ ] shows that we're telling
Republicans complete and utter [ __ ]
that they wanted to hear instead of
reality that is the difference between
us me you Gabe the difference between us
is I will turn to a Democrat and say
that's the dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] I've
ever heard
they will never do that I I said
yesterday on the show it's going to be a
really stupid thing and I'm gonna have
to combat it I'm gonna have to tell the
audience this over and over and over I
think do not pay attention to the
Democratic race in 2024 don't do it Joe
Biden is going to be the nominee don't
spend your time don't spend your energy
don't spend your treasure don't spend
your hot air on that race that is not a
race that is going to be had don't do it
stupid and I'm gonna have to yeah
[ __ ] hard it is you know how [ __ ]
hard it is for an incumbent president to
lose a race
[ __ ] [ __ ] up as Donald Trump there
won't be a challenger there won't be I'm
telling you right now there will not be
primaries I mean there will be because
there has to be but there will be only
one name that is going to Prevail in all
those primaries there's no one going to
challenge him they're not going to do it
there's no [ __ ] way they can at this
point as long as he wants to be the
nominee he will be don't waste your
energy on it what you should waste your
energy on is pointing out dumb [ __ ]
like this you want to see some more
marketeers here's some more marketeers
listen to this this is great I don't
know who the [ __ ] these chuckleheads are
but this is fantastic listen to this
Katie Hobbs is the projected winner the
race has been called by multiple sources
as being completed and the reason why
it's been called is exactly what we've
expected and what Mark was saying was
the fact that the races will always be
called for the Democrat candidate when
they've collected enough votes to win
and in
Katie Hobbs has have enough votes to win
almost the entire time yeah she's been
up she's been ahead twenty thousand
thirty thousand votes at different times
this last drop actually lowered her her
lead from 30 000 to like twenty thousand
yeah this is dumb stupid [ __ ] again yeah
she had she had the votes to win the
second the polls closed right period
right right I know a lot of them they
just had to count them right right A lot
of them were like oh we're really
waiting on E day drops like e day's like
[ __ ] D-Day that's gonna like win them
the [ __ ] uh the the candidate to be
the the the
um then the actual person that's brought
in office right hoping that the E day
votes are going to outweigh the the the
mail-in votes or the absentee ballots or
or whichever one they're trying to
dismiss right and you hear it again and
again and again throughout this whole
thing
Kerry Lake
[ __ ] and moans about how long the
process is taking
these these longer processes hand
counting process has been implemented by
republican-controlled state legislators
Arizona is another example then you have
to have Bill Gates who is the Republican
head of the uh Maricopa County not not
the Microsoft Bill Gates yeah it's not
Microsoft building another Bill Gates we
don't want to get too many conspiracy
theories right
but again I mean though understandable
how someone might think Bill Gates
George Soros they could make that
connection I could see how they might
make that just based on the name alone
but you've got Bill Gates who's the
supervisor of the the
uh Board of Elections Board of Elections
in Maricopa right there's I think
there's four members three of them are
Republican one of them is Democrat so if
anyone wants to [ __ ] and moan about
that [ __ ] just understand that majority
of Republicans and the leader the head
of it is a republican he went on to CNN
and other places to be like I'm sorry
that she has to feel this way I wish it
was faster too but this is the [ __ ] we
do
and we want to make sure I especially as
a republican want to make sure that
these are all legal valid votes so we're
going to count them we're going to make
sure we count them right and she and
then he even said he's like I would
think someone like Carrie Lake would
totally want this to be the fact because
all of these people these Republicans
want to [ __ ] and moan about oh it's
taking too long and this yeah [ __ ] it's
taking too long but why do you think
it's taking too long because you're not
willing to implement certain systems in
place because you're trying to prevent
the counting until after the polls close
for a certain ballots that are that are
coming in you are trying to uh
disenfranchise voters by making it
slower by only counting certain votes
only counting the day of not counting
the mail-in absentee provisional you
want to hold those off and when you
realize that those come in
not not them having a realization of oh
[ __ ] we should actually be supportive of
this stuff they go oh we should cancel
Mainland voting we should make the
voting agent uh higher to 21 we should
repeal the 26th amendment all dumb
[ __ ] ideas again within their own
Echo chamber they continue to repeat
this [ __ ] and in 2024 they will not
realize the mistakes they've made again
because they continue to push the most
ridiculous
Solutions and I say that in air codes
Solutions because Republicans don't
offer any well let's listen to the rest
of this in Texas Paul you tell me if you
think Gabe is spot on watch this [ __ ]
that they say about the founding fathers
it's oh it's so [ __ ] dumb and it's
delicious in many of these states there
are theoretically more Democrat voters
and Republicans that's why our founding
fathers did not set up our Republic to
be a pure democracy they don't want
stupid [ __ ] morons who haven't done
[ __ ] in their life to be voting all
these all this movement to the left uses
like on you know on Instagram and
Facebook and go out and vote vote no
don't vote you [ __ ] idiot don't vote
you are stupid you are a degenerate
piece of scum Your Existence is menial
in fact God loves you most of us don't
your own family doesn't support you very
much because you're intolerable your
views are not well thought out it's not
your ssris and your depression your
mental illness that is making you
miserable it's it's the fact that you
don't live for anything you stand for
nothing so everything gives you value
and you watch Tick Tock as a hobby so
your life doesn't exist in any real
substance so no you shouldn't vote
the projection is real with this one but
what do you think about the founding
fathers part there Texas ball Jesus
Christ yeah he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] I tell
you what this guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] I
just I can't I can't with these [ __ ]
people anymore I just I just can't you
know what's this guy's name Elijah
don't know who it is you know I mean
let's talk about founding fathers for
just 10 seconds okay when the founding
fathers
had ideas I mean half the [ __ ] world
thought the world was flat the the
nobody could [ __ ] read
I mean their ideas were based on a
country that had less people in it than
California has to [ __ ] day
you know there's no [ __ ] way the
founding fathers could even Envision one
state in their precious country having
40 [ __ ] million people in it
that would that would have made that
that would have sent most of them home
crying to think about writing a [ __ ]
Constitution that had to deal with just
that issue alone so can we please stop
talking about the founding fathers like
they [ __ ] are the end-all be-all of
everything because they aren't because
they were huge they were humble enough
to know we need to make this document to
be able to change because we can't see
it all coming
right well I mean not only not only that
this guy's talking about the governor's
race in Arizona
in the state where the state has the
Constitution where the federal
government grants the right of the state
to I don't know pick how they [ __ ] do
the poll do the polling the polling
places the drop boxes the early voting
the absentee voting how they do the
counting when the count how they count
what how they batch it all these all
this [ __ ] is done by the State
Constitution which when the founding
fathers are sitting around scratching
their asses trying to think up how this
country was going to be Arizona was not
a [ __ ] State and there wasn't a state
Arizona Constitution it didn't exist you
[ __ ] chuckleheads I want to do
something here we've got a a huge
audience today there's a huge audience
so I want to remind everyone hit this
subscribe button here on the YouTube
channel uh you should come by every
Tuesday Texas ball joins us every
Tuesday but every single weekday we do a
show here two full hours noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube also you
can download every episode on Apple
Spotify and Google sorry I gotta I gotta
get our uh our kicks in there just a bit
there Texas Paul I want to show you this
this video this couldn't possibly be
uh Texas bond gave the reason why Kerry
Lake lost it all this couldn't be it
let's listen I'm going to not only be
the governor of Arizona for four years
I'm going to do two terms I'm going to
be your worst freaking nightmare for
eight years and we will reform
I'm gonna be your worst freaking
nightmare for eight years who in the
actual [ __ ] would go to the poll and
like you know what I'm gonna pick the
lady who she's an elected official right
now she's really not you know she's not
crazy at all she really doesn't you know
kick over the bucket just to kick over
the bucket but this lady wants to be our
worst [ __ ] nightmare who are you
gonna vote for Texas Paul Who you gonna
vote for
you know actually that's not where she
[ __ ] herself that really wasn't
Believe It or Not Maga loves that
[ __ ] and that and that's who that
that was for was she was telling us we
Democrats she was going to be our worst
[ __ ] nightmare and my girl are like
um you know I mean they love that [ __ ]
where she [ __ ] herself was when she
said John McCain voters here here we go
here maybe yeah maybe at this moment
let's let's listen here let's listen
here see what see if this is the one we
don't have any McCain Republicans in
here do we foreign
[Music]
but see I'm but here here's here's the
thing Texas Falls I'm gonna argue here
I'm gonna argue here that this John
McCain talk that's for manga two that's
all for Manga she didn't really believe
that [ __ ] she never she she this is a
woman who probably voted more times for
John McCain than not
in Arizona oh yeah I would imagine this
idea that she thought that [ __ ]
McCain Republicans were the problem is
all [ __ ] lying she is a [ __ ] lie
the entire thing even the [ __ ] filter
it's off I mean you have to remember
that she also was a she formally
was a trump hater right when he was
elected you know and and went through
inauguration she was sharing isn't
everyone formally at some point at Trump
yeah I mean yeah I guess that's true but
that's why I love my man Gabe he brings
the receipts but even like her uh she
and in 2016 2017 she was sharing memes
on Facebook talking about how you know
we should we should uh protest this and
we shouldn't allow him to be in there
he's a [ __ ] idiot I think what did
she call him fat she bought it at one
point she body shamed him which you
can't find that tweet anymore obviously
but people have receipts on Twitter and
they're sharing them around
um but it's just another case where she
said one thing and completely pivoted
over
and said uh that oh no no he's the
Saving Grace he's the orange Jesus he's
the [ __ ] second coming of Christ he
is the orange deity that we love and
[ __ ] wanna you know the ketchup King
the ketchup King exactly you know he's
not just the Burger King he is the
ketchup King well Patriot takes had this
um post from uh telegram Patriot takes
does us all great service over there on
telegram he keeps track of this [ __ ] and
posted on Twitter so we can see what's
going on over there
um he says they are taking the carry
they are taking the Kerry Lake news well
here's some of the Greg Greg here says
not a chance this fraud cannot be
allowed to stand forensic audit of all
balance hand count verification expose
the steals send them to jail they were
counting with the cameras and people
watching Greg okay Freedom Enthusiast
says full forensic audit which okay
whatever audited you dumb [ __ ]
it ain't gonna do any good the last time
you did that you gave more votes to your
opponent and ml ml says here with the
American flag uh ml says they are demons
they are Waging War against us American
flag I don't understand we they are two
demons yeah go ahead text Paul
first of all ml I don't give a [ __ ]
about you you never crossed my [ __ ]
mind I am not Waging War on you you dumb
[ __ ] I am I don't even know I don't even
give a [ __ ] whether you live or breathe
that's why I'm Waging War on you if
you're listening it's me it's me I'm
waging more on you I'll warn you go
ahead fix it and the second thing is
these two [ __ ] that are sitting there
whining like little [ __ ] about this
[ __ ] election we're sitting there
licking Brian Kemp's taint because
they're saying that oh Hobbs was the ran
the election this can't be legal this
can't be ripe [ __ ] you Brian Kemp
[ __ ] Brian [ __ ] Kemp in
Georgia ran his own [ __ ] election and
became governor and you were all for it
you were all [ __ ] for it when we said
hey wait a minute there's some shady
[ __ ] going on here and we like held up
numbers and said this doesn't look right
you were like [ __ ] you we won get over
it well guess what [ __ ] you we won get
over it you know the other part that is
um um immensely hilarious here about
these these marketeers which again
they're super delicious have you ever
guys ever put manga tears on Cherry Pie
it I mean cherry pie is good but with
Maga tears ma it is I mean I'm more of
an apple pie kind of guy it's great on
apple pie too you could put it on pecan
pie yeah it's like it's a nice counter
like a granny smith apple right you know
a little sprinkling on your cheeseburger
a little bit and it will taste that much
better well that's I mean to go to Texas
Paul's Point all of these people are
complete they're two-faced Hypocrites in
how they say uh if it's if it's my
election and I'm winning I mean look
2020. we had votes that were across the
country okay we had votes that were uh
stop this stop the count
and uh keep counting right they were
like stop the cow don't stop the count
stop the count don't stop the count and
it literally like 2 000 miles away you
had Pennsylvania one and you had Arizona
and another and they were like stop the
count don't stop the count stop you
can't stop it in this state but don't
stop it exactly it was in this state
we're ahead stop it we're behind in this
state don't stop keep going and that is
what is that is what they do and you saw
it even on Election night they saw that
the [ __ ] red tide tsunami [ __ ]
wave that was coming was like a brick on
the tip of your finger from a paper cup
not even close and they saw that was
changing Charlie Kirk was like if you're
in line don't get out of line which is
probably the first time I've ever heard
a republican tell that to a voter mm-hmm
then he was like oh we're people are
being told to get on like no they're
fine why would he why would he assume
that those people online were going to
vote for Kerry Lake anyways right that's
a dumb assumption it's just a bunch of
people
but but then he goes on uh on that day
and he was like oh [ __ ] this is not
going the way that we want you got to
stay in line you got to do this you know
uh they're pushing lies about uh
accepting ballots that were date marked
on the 14th when that's not the case
they were accepting ballots in
Pennsylvania up to the 14th that were
postmarked
from election day which was the eighth
well don't expect them to [ __ ] adhere
to fans exactly yeah yeah and that's it
here's an here's another clip here's
another clip now this is back in August
do you remember do you remember the Nazi
reality they had down at CPAC in Texas
Texas which one was that
which one yeah it's kind of hard to but
it's one where um the Hungarian Hitler
came over here and they they hailed at
his feet
um and then Carrie link went on stage
and said this
[Applause]
yeah
we drove a stake through the heart of
the McCain machine
I think she's talking about her primary
there but see again Texas ball I think
to your point it's not about a primary
race this time it's about trying to run
a general election not just trying to
piss off [ __ ] Rhino I've got to say
it's an outstanding [ __ ] idea for you
to say we don't want your Republican
votes we don't want Europe but we only
want these Republican votes that's a
[ __ ] brilliant Primo idea but you
know what I like my marketeers huh
what's it you think I forgot you
[ __ ]
so are you gonna eat this thing live
here or are we is that what we're gonna
do no no no I thought we were gonna eat
it okay all right all right all right so
next Tuesday all right all right next
Tuesday we will make sure keep your meat
sticks and your tortillas and your
cheese keep your keep your meat sticks
in your sheath there their Texas ball do
not whip out your meat sticks yet we are
not ready for meat stick lunch okay but
but here's what we'll do I came
completely prepared for you to not be
ready for this so I brought me some real
food what do you got
real tacos tortillas tamales I've got
yeah baby I've got my guacamole
my pico de gallo oh my God he ain't
messing around man breakfast my old
lady's the best dude my old lady is the
best man I'm telling you I am telling
you if you want to be happy the rest of
your life
make a Hispanic woman your wife dude I'm
telling you
so why we're on the uh subject of of
tacos
um the other night I went through Taco
Bell now gabier is not is not a he says
that in Texas Paul and you can tell me
this he says that Taco Bell tacos are
not tacos I think we've went all this
before but I wanna I wanna hash this out
again because I'll tell you I went
through I may have had a few drinks in
me it's possible that it was late at
night and I had already had some drinks
in me
um and I had Taco Bell and I don't know
if they were talking tonight but they
were [ __ ] delicious so you know just
like I'm sure the slim jim cheese whiz
Taco will be a great thing too but tell
me Texas well do you think Taco Bell is
tacos
yeah yeah I do I mean they're shitty
tacos but they're tacos but you know you
can't you can't
and everybody and the games are games a
freaking liar here he's normally
straight as can be but Gabe's a freaking
liar here I guarantee you we put six
beers in that dude and he'll be sitting
right next to us and [ __ ] talking to
me
I ever had my life dude
I did not come here more
you give him a handful of gummies and
you know four or five beers the guy's
gonna be chopping those things down like
an alligator
you know if you're if you're trying to I
feel like it's a little fair you're
trying to add like performance enhancing
drugs in terms of my appetite you know
hey you gotta do what you got to do with
the Taco Bell it's true you sometimes
you got to have those performance
enhancing drugs and you got to be honest
man you gotta I mean you gotta be honest
I mean everybody likes to [ __ ] about
Taco Bell but we all go get a [ __ ]
burrito there and you cannot [ __ ] up a
tortilla beans and cheese I don't give a
damn dude you cannot [ __ ] that up so
people need to shut up about Taco Bell
look yeah look I can tell you I can
count on my hand how many times I've
been to Taco Bell uh like three times
I've been to T I've been to Delta this
is ridiculous I don't know if Del taco
is more than just a California West
Coast thing but Del Taco I've been to a
few times as well but only I've only
I've only done those on like a road trip
and I've only done those in the last
like
10 years of being California Jesse says
here on Facebook she says Taco Bell is
what you eat when you need to take a
crap I'm not gonna I'm not gonna dispute
that Jesse it really it might look the
same on the way out that it goes in I
don't know I mean I'm not saying I'm not
saying for sure you're right that the
next day after I had the midnight tacos
that I did not have the you know the
midnight though the one thing I saw
somebody I saw somebody mention uh what
else do they got here they they
mentioned uh Jack in the Box
but that's I don't see for that I the
first time I encountered it that's not a
[ __ ] Taco yeah
I was on a road trip through from
Illinois and I went down to go visit
some friends in Kansas and then Nebraska
and I encountered a Jack In The Box on
the way and we stopped to go to the
bathroom and I was like what did oh that
does look good but we stopped on the way
and I was like what the [ __ ] is this
thing in the window and it was just a
slice of cheese in a tortilla with meat
and I was like this is this is not a
what is this now I want to say I want to
say the other day I was on the and I
think I sent this to you Gabe I think I
was on Instagram or something or maybe
it was Twitter it was Twitter because
Elon is [ __ ] up Twitter crazy and and
Pizza Hut was advertising on Twitter
they're taking advantage of the cheap
ass inventory that there is and and
Pizza Hut right now has these [ __ ]
and they must know who the [ __ ] I am
they must have saw that I retweeted that
[ __ ] slim jim Taco thing because they
have like these pizza Taco things that
you dip I I forget what they're called
right now but Pizza Daddy things and
they were advertising and I sent to game
I'm like hey they got my number on the
taco thing on the air
it's it's crazy it's crazy
um okay well should we get back okay
does not belong on a Taco okay it really
does not okay processed meat does not
belong on a Taco I mean because [ __ ]
hamburger is cheap
just like processed meat does not does
not belong in the governor's
um mansion in Arizona Kerry Lake does
not okay so here's Gabe's uh quick quick
uh take from uh what was that that
you're working on I think let's let's
watch This Is It just me or does Carrie
lake look like she's always filming a
daytime soap opera lake is so far down
the rabbit hole with Trump that she has
refused to commit to accepting the
results of her own election will you
accept the results of your election in
November
I'm going to win the election and I will
accept that result if you lose will you
accept that
I'm gonna win the election and I will
accept that result which is a little bit
awkward since she just lost her election
to Arizona's current Secretary of State
Katie Hobbs oops oops so just so you
know this was so I I future proofed the
last what was that because I talked I I
[ __ ] on her and I [ __ ] on [ __ ] Mark
fincham so this is this is a this is a
this isn't hey this isn't this is one
outtake from what was that because I
couldn't include it even though I was
anticipating based on the accounts like
all right I feel like I'm pretty
confident about this outcome
but I could not do it in the event that
some some ballots came back and then It
reversed the account which I didn't you
didn't want to be wrong is what you're
saying yeah I didn't want to be wrong or
I didn't want to be spreading
misinformation yeah exactly or ahead of
when it was called or like or like in an
echo chamber so it went live on Sunday
and they didn't announce it yet so this
was in that was just like waiting in the
wings and then when it got announced
last night I just like cut it together
and boom I was like ship it speaking of
having it live here's MSNBC msnbc's
um announcement here the the tile and
Kerry looks like she's got way too much
vaseline on her camera ones there what
do you think
no you know what man I everybody's
getting that wrong everybody's saying
she needs to quit using filters and this
and that it's not a [ __ ] filter if
you look at these two women you
understand why one is prepared to run
the government and the other one is
smoking [ __ ] ganja like there is no
tomorrow man that is not a filter hot
room is filled with [ __ ] smoke man
and it's right in front of your face
yeah I'm telling you it's there's a
[ __ ] Haze hanging pull her picture up
there's a [ __ ] Haze in that room man
since College
I want I I wanted to show this clip
yesterday
um you know the great Howard Stern
um you know he's he's kind of moved from
Shack Jack to you know reasonable Jack I
guess she'd gone now just because
there's so much crazy but he talks about
the crazy here in this clip and it's
it's sometimes he's way off the mark but
on this one I think he's on let's listen
world's just become so [ __ ] nutty all
I can tell you is the one glimmer of
happiness I had and I said this earlier
was the elections on the midterm
elections because I think crazy got
voted down for the most part yes they're
still crate there's still a lot of
people voting for crazy
don't get me wrong bud
at the end of the day I was glad enough
Americans stood up and said you know
what
I I when somebody when a pilot
mainstream politician from one of the
two parties gets up and says the
elections are fixed with no evidence and
they just keep repeating it doesn't
matter I don't have any evidence but I
know they're fixed when I lose their fix
that's when crazy husty you cannot be a
part of a party
I was hearing a statistic that's crazy
it said 29 of people who voted said the
reason they voted was to oppose the
pro-trump candidates because they
believe in democracy
and that is the rub that's why that's
why democracy won here Texas Paul
and you know I've got to ask you two a
question I want to do I I've been this
this has been rattling around in my head
I want to ask you two a question yeah
um the Republicans are unabashedly
gerrymandering to the extreme
okay well that's the reason why Rhonda
Santa's in Florida went went red
yeah the reason we didn't absolutely
[ __ ] kill last night is that
California and New York went with legit
Maps they went with maps that were drawn
in a nonpartisan fashion and look what
the [ __ ] happened up in Long Island
right
like
I'm having a hard time fighting with one
hand tied behind my back I'm just not my
DNA is not written that way you pull a
[ __ ] knife on me I pull a [ __ ] gun
on you you know what I'm saying these
[ __ ] are telling us they're gonna
gerrymander
if we win we're not gonna [ __ ] them
we're not we're gonna give them health
care for Christ's sake
why the [ __ ] don't we gerrymander the
[ __ ] out of our Maps
and quit taking that goddamn High Road
I mean
am I the only one thinking this way guys
I mean really I mean I I just I know I'm
saying the quiet part out loud but we
keep doing this as a party
I mean yeah our pretzels principles are
important yeah we believe in democracy
yeah but God damn it we can have real
democracy real Fair [ __ ] elections
when we put this [ __ ] Republican
party down for a dirt nap I mean these
[ __ ] are outright telling us we're
gonna cheat and then when when we kick
their ass anyways because we're really
doing things for the American people
they shouldn't say you cheated and it's
like a slap in the face it's because you
know how bad we could have [ __ ] you
Republicans yesterday on November 8th
you I mean we could have [ __ ] taken
the house plus 20 seats if we wanted to
because of where the seats were up for
election we could have Jerry mandered
the [ __ ] out of Oregon we could have
gerrymandered the [ __ ] out of Washington
state we could have gerrymandered the
[ __ ] out of California
and just bent you over
and that's it
and then you turn around and have the
[ __ ] nuts to tell us we cheated when
you obviously [ __ ] cheated and the
governors in the states proudly in
[ __ ] Ohio they took a map that had
been the courts had shut down and
they've pushed it through anyways and
said we're going to do it the [ __ ]
anyways
well the chat the chat agrees with you
here the chats uh lighten up that yeah
you're you're um you're correct Gabe
what do you think and then I'll give my
my two cents on
yeah so I it's I think it's a I think
it's a I mean it's a valid question
right like any time we go through this
uh you will have a party that and and
when I say a party I mean Republican
party will cheat however whatever
however means necessary they'll change
the voting age if they can they'll uh
redistrict the areas to say that a large
area only gets you know majority from a
smaller population or region
um
there's a there it's hard because like a
part of me I'm like yeah [ __ ] it why not
like why wouldn't we do this right if we
know
that
social programs and Democratic policies
actually benefit
Americans and don't leave them by the
wayside for a politician's own
kind of benefit
there's a part of me that says yeah we
should right but then there's a part of
me that is very I don't know it's hard
because like I I understand 100 where
you're coming from because I'm like yeah
why would we give
why would we take the high road why
would we allow for someone to cheat that
we know is going to cheat and we don't
do anything to prevent it now there
could be ways in which we pass laws that
stop this right I I'm not a legal expert
especially in constitutional law and
like election law like I don't know what
can be done and what can be passed
but then if there is a part of me that
says oh if we do that then we're just as
bad right we take away the say
of the people
and it's kind of like um
I guess the way I would look at is like
there's a part of me that looks at like
parenting right a parent does something
for their children
when they regardless of what the child
says they're like oh this is actually
you know it's best if we do XYZ because
you don't know the full picture
uh and kind of like babying people and
then I feel like if we do that then we
lose that
I don't know I feel like there's even
more resistance you know not even not
from so much from people in our party
but there there'll be they're real
they're I feel like there really would
be that aspect of like this Republican
Civil War that they won
so I don't know I mean the way that Tony
take let me give you the attorney take
so here's here's what I'll say about
gerrymandering
we actually participate in
gerrymandering all 50 states this is
what we do
um Democrats uh now it doesn't always go
our way what I mean by that is Democrats
need to win more state legislators which
the funny part is is Democrats didn't
give away one state legislator they
gained state legislators in this
election that is a huge thing in
midterms because here's the thing we
can't gerrymander [ __ ] if we don't have
these state legislators and really what
we need to do at a state legislator
um level is not gerrymandered
necessarily it's to make sure that more
people have access to the ballot
um and in a way that is appropriate for
the state I think it was Nevada
um they they went to ranked Choice
voting Alaska's done it uh Maine's done
it there are several states that have
ranked Choice voting and which you know
we can argue the merits of ranked Choice
voting but I believe ranked Choice
voting actually hurts the possibility
for either party to jerryman under a
state because you it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter in the re in in a
head-to-head match of party versus party
when you're doing rank Choice voting you
may be voting for a Republican and
Republican or Democrat and a Democrat so
I think there are ways that we as a
democracy and we as pro-democracy people
can gerrymander it to where it's fair as
[ __ ] right and what I mean by that is
that if you actually participate in what
your civic duty is inside not just your
country but your state your county your
city the School Board District all those
things if you can manage and again it's
tough we got lives you know you got job
you get kids grandkids you gotta Texas
Paul's got to have his tacos I mean
these things these things take time
right out of your day and and I
understand that it's hard but if we can
get more people being less ignorant
about how our system works and what the
design of it actually is is to deliver
the result adults that we the people the
voters want I I don't think we even have
to have discussions 20 30 years from now
about gerrymandering I think I think 30
20 30 years from now we we will look
behind us and say remember when we did
that stupid gerrymandering thing how
dumb was that we waited 30 years to get
the [ __ ] that we wanted in this country
because we let we let people gerrymander
the [ __ ] out of districts so I agree
that gerrymandering is it is a must and
what I mean by that is we have to
gerrymander in a way that gives the
power back to the voter it gives the
power back to the electorate and the
only way we do that in across the
country is for people to be less
ignorant about the system that we have
that is more important than I think you
know carving out you know this
neighborhood or that neighborhood
they're they're going to continue to do
this because the only way they can win
is to gerrymander that's it that is the
only way they can win or or rely on us
not to gerrymander like like Texas Paul
is saying I mean like Texas ball saying
they relied on us not to gerrymander as
much as they did and they're only
possibly going to have one maybe two
votes in the house here
and don't get me wrong I don't think we
are because we're not wired that way I
mean our Maps we want our maps to be
legitimate we want to win legitimately
it's kind of in our DNA
but when you have a situation like
Larose up in Hawaii Ohio
when when [ __ ] Mike dewine they carve
out a map that even a republican judge
looks at and says no no
we're not doing this
yeah and they say we're just gonna run
we're gonna sit here with our arms
crossed we're going to keep this map
whether you [ __ ] like it or not judge
and we're going to run out the time on
this election
and there's nothing you can do about it
because we already printed the ballots
and they say it openly openly I think at
that point we as Democrats need to unify
a little tighter as a party because I
think when Mike dewine pulled that [ __ ]
we should have held up [ __ ]
California's map in Arizona and pardon
me uh New York's map and said we will
[ __ ] end you this election
you try that with your little ass
[ __ ] state of Ohio and we will
[ __ ] end the Republican party this
election and that threat is real
I think we need to get
to be some pipette and Son of sons of
[ __ ] we really do I mean I don't
think that we need to run to cheating
and run to [ __ ] gerrymandering but I
think when a governor in a state
like [ __ ] Rhonda Santa says you know
what I'm going to cheat and I'm going to
cheat openly
I think we need to say your party's on
the line because we do we have the most
populous [ __ ] states in the country
if you look at a voting map we are so
[ __ ] [ __ ] every election because we
have such tight populations and they
draw these [ __ ] districts that don't
benefit us even though we are the mass
the most populous we could carve those
districts down block by block and no
Republican in the state of [ __ ] New
York would win an election ever again
Paul do you want to ever [ __ ] again
do you want to know why heavier popular
dairies are more quote unquote liberal
do you wonder why
the reason why is because in heavily
populated areas they have to actually
govern they have to they do not have a
choice right like in a in a bigger city
and I've never lived in a big city but
in a bigger city they have to worry
about things like sewer trash utility I
mean they have to worry about traffic
traffic lights they have to worry about
a lot of other things that they have to
govern they have to in rural areas they
don't have to govern those things
because they don't exist and what
happens is is when you have to govern
you understand the system of government
and you become a quote-unquote liberal
which is really [ __ ] stupid that
anyone tags that as a bad as a bad as a
bad tag anyways the the reason why
there's more liberals in these bigger
areas is because they are forced to
govern correctly they are forced to get
and sometimes they fail right I mean
governments fail feel they don't
sometimes make the right decisions
that's why we have elections is to get
rid of the people who make bad decisions
in our government but they have to
govern in rural areas there's not as
much to govern there just isn't and the
reason why more people are conserved in
rural areas and they're less liberal and
they're less you know akin to government
and ignorant of what government systems
do is because they don't do it they
don't have that practice because there's
not the practice to be had that is why
in our country we have this Dynamic of
oh liberals and are live in blue cities
no that's not true humans live there
they're people just like everyone
[ __ ] else and if you went and you
lived there for just a little bit of
time you would understand that you are
going to rely on government to make sure
that your city your town is operating
properly properly that is what you would
have to do and and the more they would
see that that the more liberal they
would get but we're all liberal every
last one of us are the other the other
thing I would add to that too is like
you know if you were to look at why
teams at companies are successful it's
because they are composed of diverse
backgrounds right uh you've got someone
who has this many years or they have
this background or they came from this
socioeconomic background or what have
you right it's it
when you are run by a Republican
government or leadership
it's
the definition of insanity right you're
doing the same thing over and over again
expecting a different result
and you find that when you work within
an echo chamber when you have the same
people spewing the same policies and the
same
Solutions over and over again for years
thinking that this is going to fix the
problem when it really just makes the
problem even more [ __ ] up and they go
well in order to fix that problem we
need to do this thing and it becomes
it's a compounding effect of [ __ ] up
on on the people that are voting these
people in right
and so the reason that successful groups
happen are because of diverse
backgrounds and may they make the best
decisions they've got a diverse option
and pool of people to chime in and give
feedback and say based on my experience
or based on things I've done in the past
this won't work or we should apply this
Theory to this or what have you have a
you have challenging Minds that surface
to the top the best solution the best
way to govern the best policies
um so that's the
we lost Gabe there we lost him in mid
Midstream he must have he must have hit
the button here that or his power went
off
um but I think I think I think it's uh
oh here he is maybe the Republicans they
try to cut me off it's the Deep State
basically the tldrr is
diverse backgrounds especially in higher
population areas like cities do better
because those have a better group of
people offering Solutions right and when
you have a republican that comes in
smaller area or takes over a large area
they [ __ ] up because they have people
that are just yes men and yes women
right or yes people that come in and say
oh yeah we should do that we should do
that would you do that nothing that
actually challenges and says Ah actually
this might be a better way to look at
this so that's why I I believe that
cities typically do better or like are
more liberal it's because they have
policies that actually benefit social
programs that benefit the people that
are there as opposed to a republican
let's say Texas Paul give us your take
on this and then I want to move to the
announcement topic here well you're both
hitting it right on the head it's just
really obvious I mean Republicans can't
govern because they come out of Rural
America they do I mean Texas has a
handful of cities and the rest of the
state is [ __ ] empty it is it's just I
mean there's actually a county that had
nobody vote in it I mean it's there's
nobody [ __ ] there
um it's just it's just the way it is but
I will tell you I I and and I'll sum
this up with saying this okay
I'm getting a lot of flack for being an
election denier
but El Paso County El Paso County had 30
000 less votes this election in a
turnout election for us
I mean the numbers don't lie Democrats
showed the [ __ ] up in this election this
is this is
uh thirty thousand less votes in El Paso
right all 30 000 votes to all 30 000
people that didn't show up were
Democrats
because the Republicans didn't lose a
[ __ ] vote in that county
all 30 000 of the votes that didn't show
up from 2018 to 20
were
Democrats and what's impossible to
believe about that is
that's Beto's hometown
so you're telling me 30 000 Democrats
didn't show up in the hometown of the
most popular candidate we've had for
years in in an election where we had the
best slate of candidates I mean just if
you looked at the candidate quality that
the Democrats offered up this time in
Texas it was [ __ ] amazing it was just
a we had the best slate of candidates in
Forever in an election that was a blue
turnout election and 30 000 people less
people showed up in El Paso County our
our our Governor's Hometown and they
were all Democrats so please Republicans
why not was it I I want to say maybe
Beto should call the Secretary of State
of Texas and see if he could get thirty
thousand uh 426 votes if they could just
find those for him maybe he should yeah
yeah uh you know here's the thing though
bring it Republicans you want to [ __ ]
count let's count
you know Abbott's pushing that election
denier [ __ ] and and we're going to find
out what happened in Harris County like
like Harris County Democrats did
something to the to people right no no
you want to count [ __ ] let's
count let's get there is there anyone
that's proposing to to recount
Abbott wants to look at Abbott wants to
look at Harris County because he thinks
he can pin this on Harris County
Democrats
for having [ __ ] people over
he really is opening that Genie's bottle
well hey you know
you know so and speak I mean if you open
one I would imagine that you then you
create the present and say like well
then why don't we open them all up it's
Pandora's Box speaking of speaking of
stupid and stupid as a stupid does
um the Cheeto dust q and honor is going
to be making an announcement Rosebud
asked a question here are you going to
be live streaming tonight for Trump
Dumpty announcement no I'm not going to
live stream it but we definitely will be
covering it tomorrow so you will
definitely know what I think about the
Cheeto dust q and honors a little
announcement that he's gonna make
whatever it is Texas Paul I hope this
little [ __ ] runs I hope he [ __ ] runs
and I hope he leans all the way into
that son of a [ __ ] everyone keeps
saying oh Democrats are terrified and
they're losing their minds because
Trump's gonna announce I'm like what are
you smoking no this is beautiful no
better time after the biggest loss that
he's ever had
then right now for you to announce
that's great that's great
I will you know and I'm I'm in a 100
agreement with you I think it's [ __ ]
fantastic that he's out there I think
that that every time he opens his mouth
it's good for us but I just want to warn
Democrats about one thing my fellow
Democrat Trump was not on the election
not on the ballot this election anywhere
he was private citizen Trump during this
election
Ron DeSantis was on the ballot and they
[ __ ] lost Nationwide
Ohio Mike dewine was on the ballot and
they [ __ ] lost young Canada was on
the ballot and they are well Junkin
wasn't on the ballot but anyway they
almost screwed up there and Abbott was
on the ballot and they [ __ ] lost
Nationwide
let's kick the right people in the nuts
I mean Trump trump was a [ __ ] loser
this election and I love dump dunking on
him
but the leaders of the Republican party
which are the governors at this point
there is no National leadership you
think Kevin McCarthy leads the
Republican party you're [ __ ] crazy
you think Mitch McConnell has control of
anything he can't even get them to
declare him speaker easily yeah I mean
you've got you've got so you've got a
lover's quarrel happening between him
Matt Gates and Marjorie Taylor green
right now but also I mean yes I want to
reiterate what Texas Paul just said they
all of these people and even people that
weren't running you had Ted Cruz doing
his bus tour campaign all of these
people push forward a bunch of these
pro-trump election denier [ __ ]
candidates these crazy people keep in
mind there were
291 election deniers on the ballot I
don't know the final count uh but it's
significantly less than that
for a 291 election deniers and a lot of
these people all of these different
candidates Ron DeSantis was doing he was
he was stumping for other people Ted
Cruz wasn't running but he was stumping
for other people and all of the
candidates that they were pushing
[ __ ] lost the only one that really
won in the in in that in the Trump
sphere was JD Vance right and you could
look at that for the way that they
redistrict Ohio right and you could look
at the way that they actually put that
forward but other states that these
candidates these deniers are running in
I mean
Arizona was the biggest one on the map
that we were waiting for
well that's the one they wanted the most
yeah that was the one they wanted the
most because remember like it was it was
Wisconsin Pennsylvania Arizona Georgia
these are all states that they were
looking to have these were all the the
swing states that they were uh looking
to have last election in 2020 and they
didn't get and they won them for 2020.
they want them for 2024 and they needed
to make sure they had either the
governor the Secretary of State who
signs off on these they needed those
people in power and what we found was uh
all of these election deniers [ __ ]
lost in
um in their way actually the only one
who I think didn't lose was Nevada
Governor
um what's his [ __ ] name uh
the governor-elect of of Nevada he just
he won
I I don't know his name here's what I'll
tell you about Trump in this election If
he if he announces
Trump is not going to run against Joe
Biden this is not going to be a general
election he has to run a primary he's
not an incumbent this time yeah he he
handily became the nominee when he was
an incumbent president he he had to
fight like hell in 2016. now in this
primary that is about to take place and
I hope
I hope that there's four or five of
these idiots that that throw in uh Larry
Hogan being one possibly Chris Christie
uh Rhonda Santos
um maybe maybe an outlier like uh that
[ __ ] stupid Governor from Oklahoma
[ __ ]
um but here's the thing no I'm serious I
think I think we're gonna have some
people that you never [ __ ] heard of
and they they think they're gonna pick
up the Trump vote because he's gonna be
indicted that that's that's no question
here
um that's why he's running now that's
why he's announcing now is because he's
going to be indicted otherwise he'd wait
till the summer
um to to actually announce here's what
I'll tell you is this election is not
going to be against Joe Budden this is
going to be an election Republican
versus Republican and they are going to
be kicking and having a bloodbath on
each other which is not going to make
any [ __ ] sense whatsoever if you
think that this election is gonna make
any kind of sense because they're going
to be saying the exact [ __ ] they've been
saying the last year they're going to be
talking about bathrooms kids genitalia
being mutilated they're going to be
talking about marrying 16 year olds
making sure that 10 year old girls are
forced to have [ __ ] babies they're
going to be talking about taking away
women's rights taking away voting rights
from gen Z they're going to add that to
the list they're going to be debating
these topics with each other and only
only exposing themselves even [ __ ]
more
text Paul did you have something you
want to add there
yeah yeah
um I want to make a call Trump wins this
Civil War
yeah yeah absolutely Trump wins this
Civil War because Trump would literally
murder Ivanka Trump Ivana Ivanka Trump
on [ __ ] camera
if it would hand him the election
no other Republican out there will sink
as low as Trump will sink
do you think
do you think his ship sinks though
before he can sink that low
now they're trying to shove [ __ ] in his
pocket and and throw him out the [ __ ]
plane you got to remember Trump has been
in court his entire [ __ ] life
everybody wants to think that Trump's
[ __ ] in his pants and this hat and the
other no Trump believes in his and you
know he's [ __ ] don't get me wrong he's
[ __ ] but in his mind he's not
in his mind he's going to drag this [ __ ]
out and drag this [ __ ] out and drag this
[ __ ] out even if you [ __ ] convict him
he is going to appeal it they're not
going to lock him up in prison during
the appeal and he's going to run and he
will [ __ ] gut Rhonda Santos he will
gut him and then dance on his [ __ ]
intros on the [ __ ] floor because
Rhonda Santos is a little cuck you know
that ready he's such a little [ __ ] when
he when he walked up to that that young
kid with the mask on he's like take that
mask off you're a disgrace or whatever
like dude you little [ __ ] talking to a
teenager like that you also it's like
why you know I in that moment it in that
specific moment that was that was uh
Rhonda sand is being triggered as [ __ ]
right because here's the thing he's not
speaking to those kids those kids are
behind him he doesn't have to see them
he's talking to the reporters that are
there he's triggered because oh [ __ ]
Florida is supposed to be this maskless
area this area that defeated kovid
because of sunshine and [ __ ]
debaucherous dumbass yeah whatever
but though that that is the moment where
he saw he's like oh this is gonna this
is ruined my image because this goes
against the exact narrative God forbid
somebody cares about themselves and the
people around them in their community
and wants to actually protect themselves
from getting and spreading a virus so
that other people are in contact and
possibly get sick or die depending what
their health state is also
it was Joe Lombardo is who I was
thinking of is the trump-backed account
who was the who's the governor-elect the
other thing though is what you guys
brought up was I believe that okay so if
we think of this realistically in the
timeline right now
it is November 15th tonight Trump most
likely based on what I've been seeing
online he keeps pushing this [ __ ] about
like he shared the Patriot takes tweet
about Ron desantis's Maga ad yeah the ad
that we showed yesterday that and then
he had he had a tweet or sorry a truth
[ __ ] so dumb a truth on Truth social
that said hopefully today will turn out
to be one of the most important days in
the history of our country he's three
hours ahead so he he wrote that 12 hours
ago
um at
my time 10 21 so 1 21 a.m he was awake
and he sent out this truth saying
hopefully today will turn out
he's spreading memes about uh dude he
was he was on me we were hosting Rampage
right making America great again once
again
like all again and again like again and
again and again here's the thing here's
the thing here's the thing like right
now look at this on Twitter number 24
trending is Ivermectin this is how
[ __ ] dumb this is right now now you'd
say Tony what does this have to do with
him announcing it has everything to do
with him announcing this is gonna get
Dumber they are going to get dumber and
dumber as he [ __ ] tries to run a race
folks what who what is he going to do
what is he going to run against what
policies is he going to say the reason
why you never have this is the reason
why you never have someone announcing
that they're going to run for the next
presidential election before they even
figure out who has won the house
for the current election is because it's
dumb as [ __ ] it's the dumbest thing that
any political person could ever do and
it only shows how [ __ ] dumb he is and
he has no he has no understanding of how
our government works he has no
understanding how election Cycles work
and he has no [ __ ] understanding what
the office of president of the president
is he has no clue and he was in it and
he has no [ __ ] clue well he can't he
he cannot because here's the thing again
if you look at the Timeline you have two
years until you know another election or
another uh yeah another election
and right now what you see is a guy that
lost [ __ ] huge on TV he lost huge on
the [ __ ] public stage he backed all
these people all these election deniers
all these people who were saying oh 2020
count the dish and don't count that
[ __ ] and five hey hey Gabe I don't
mean to interrupt you here um it looks
like there's some news I saw Article
Five was uh trending
um and I'm not sure on this we need to
check but it looks like um the reports
are that a Russian missile has hit NATO
territory
um and no word if there's going to be
invoking of Article Five I'm not sure of
the let's see it looks like yeah
um bno news has this is that a reliable
source I believe it's a reliable source
isn't it yeah if you go to the profile
you'll see there's one that's like that
yeah I just want to make sure this is a
reliable breaking I think this is it
yeah that's the one breaking suspected
missile hits Village in Poland killing
two people
um this is uh if this is true that Rush
Russia has fired a missile into Poland
territory
um this could be the moment that article
5 is invoked here
um we'll see here's
express.co.uk can you check this are you
double checking this game yeah um it
looks like at least two are dead after
Russia Mich lands
um in Poland that is a big big
aggressive move and this is just within
the last half hour I believe
um that this news is being reported
um
I don't mean to cut off our Cheeto desk
even on our stuff but this is big
breaking news here if this is yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if Russia didn't
do it actually intentionally because the
the only thing that saves Putin's ass
right now is if NATO gets involved
because you know like we'll have our
infighting and this that and the other
but if Russia [ __ ] attacked us a
republican Democrat whatever you'd face
a wall of us you know and right now
Putin's in [ __ ] trouble and the only
thing that will save his ass is if he
can drag us into this war
period so I wouldn't be surprised if if
[ __ ] like this doesn't start happening
on the regular yeah some some people are
asking if this is an automatic uh
Article Five in um to invoke I I'm not
sure just because there's a declaration
um from them I'm not sure
um so this may be the beginning of the
end for Putin if this is true if it was
an aggressive act
um it'll matter what there's Article
Five it'll matter what Poland does in
response and right now I guarantee you
Tony blinken's on the phone with the
[ __ ] prime minister uh president of
Poland and he's got him by the [ __ ]
neck saying don't do anything [ __ ]
stupid okay don't do anything [ __ ]
stupid yeah can you confirm when the
Missile hit
um yeah yeah it did because it because
it looks like from the pictures that
they have it's dark over there now
um yeah well I mean like what are they
like eight hours nine hours ahead yeah
so so they um it would be possibly night
time over there here's here's another uh
picture this is nine hours ahead of me
so right now it would be 7 38 p.m so it
looks like does it does y'all pick that
up you mind if I respond about Trump
yeah go ahead go ahead
Okay the reason I think Trump's in good
shape here is because nobody wanted a
new Coke they want the original they
wanted classic Coke and Ron DeSantis is
doing the thing with his hands and he's
doing you know what I mean he is
literally mimicking Trump both
physically rhetorically everything okay
Trump all he has to do they're trying to
shove all the [ __ ] in his pocket and
throw him out of the [ __ ] airplane as
fast as they can because they think
they're going to keep their fascism and
get all the blame stuck to Trump and
throw them out the [ __ ] plane Trump
will stand up tonight and he will say I
wasn't on the ballot if I had been on
the ballot instead of that weakling run
descendants
we would have won
and Republicans right now who are
licking their wounds and [ __ ] hurting
are going to say
yeah yeah we didn't [ __ ] win because
Trump wasn't there trouble oh yeah oh
yeah they're gonna they're gonna buy his
[ __ ] for sure 100 there's gonna be a
large number of people it's a small
small percentage but a large number of
people in this country that are going to
buy his nonsense hickline Tigger I want
to pull this up uh Hal spark stays on
top of this uh Russia step pretty good
uh Russia Ukraine stuff I love that they
have accidentally in air quotes yeah he
says uh Russia is accidentally hitting
Poland when Rockets uh breaking this is
from the town in Poland two straight
Rockets fell in the town of I'm not even
going to try to pronounce it on the
border of Ukraine
um it hit the grain dryers two people
died the police and prosecutor's office
and the Army are on site
um this is a picture again of it looks
like a green dryer truck you see the
tractor here and you can see the [ __ ]
crater that this thing created
um when it hit but um yeah it looks like
Hal is what I'm getting this from how is
Russia is saying it was an accident
um of course that's exactly what they
would say
um I was watching a video
um from Russian TV have you guys ever
noticed this when they have the Russian
TV guy all these people standing around
it looks like a deal or no deal like a
game show have you ever noticed that
that's why it's [ __ ] weird but um um
they're they were not happy they were
not happy that uh zielinski showed up uh
in Kirsten as it was taken over and
people were celebrating in the streets
they were really [ __ ] pissed off
um actually you know that's not it
um if I can find that video I'll do it
the problem is is it's in Russian so you
have to read balls like [ __ ] church
bells dude I love that guy I [ __ ]
love that guy I mean he has balls like
this freaking big he literally has to be
wheeled around on a cart because he
can't walk because his balls are that
[ __ ] big
he's always standing there you know what
I mean and he's talking but he ain't
moving because his balls are tucked
behind him so you can't see him on the
camera he's got [ __ ] balls like
basketballs dude I'm telling you bigger
bigger the girls got on his pickup truck
named fake silver I mean he's I mean
I remember you know people said oh this
would be 12 hours 12 hours Russia would
be in and out [ __ ] steam him down if
they'd be done right here we are nine
months later here we are we're you know
I we will probably be still dealing with
this in 2023 in the new year which means
we're close to a year of it happening
right which is you know from 12 hours to
12 months you got to tell me that you
know text Paul is right you're gonna
tell me that a guy also a guy that was a
TV he was a comedian you know doing
parody and satire delivering the news
understanding policy
you will not believe the [ __ ] I caught
on Twitter when I admitted that when he
was first elected I was like this guy's
a [ __ ] comedian what a joke you know
what I mean whoo and I was admitting
that I was wrong about the guy
good Lord I got so many of his freaking
resumes [ __ ] on me and 140 characters at
a time man be careful what you say about
zelinsky man
no no 100 have you have you seen some of
his acting though have you seen some of
the the I've seen some of them he was
actually pretty good yeah yeah I mean
he's definitely a better president than
he is an actor I'm just going to say
that I I'll say it I don't give a [ __ ] I
think he's a better person I've only
seen I don't know if he's done dramatic
work I've only seen the like the bits
they've done on the show right right but
then he's making
he's making Putin look like a [ __ ] is
what he's doing yeah
hid away in a [ __ ] bunker and he's
standing in a town that still has
Russian [ __ ] snipers in it and he's
standing out in the middle of the
[ __ ] square
don't you think though that it um the
reason why it seems so odd is because
for four [ __ ] years we watched the
Cheeto desk you and honor just a
genuflect to Putin and and be it his
every single bidding call I mean before
that Barack Obama you you remember the
scene where Barack Obama walked up on
Putin he's like a head taller than Putin
he's like look [ __ ] you better
cut it out
um I mean there was that scene and
everyone's like oh he should stop being
so mean to Putin like [ __ ] that until I
get him [ __ ] off I I mean I I can't wait
for the day that Vladimir Putin eats an
ammo sandwich I mean I've been waiting
for over nine months now I I mean and
you know I I put a tweet out that said
you know look at these people in cursor
look at him these are the same people
that Republicans were trying to tell us
just just a week and a half ago that
these people wanted to be Russian and
who are we to tell them they can't be
Russian well if they would just
Republican they would have just stopped
counting the votes and if they would
have just stopped down when it when when
the when the Russians were ahead then
you would know that there was there are
they're idiots they're idiots
Mitchell yeah go ahead about this
missile they're Ukraine I want to remind
everybody Ukraine is a [ __ ] huge
country I mean it's not as big as the
United States but it's a big [ __ ]
country
it is impossible to accidentally shoot a
missile all the way over Ukraine and
into Poland yeah I should have did this
on [ __ ] purpose they did it on
purpose I mean there's only two ways
that they uh
that they they kind of explain this
right or excuse this
they say
oh it was a mistake which is like how do
you how do you mistake shooting a rocket
that far or missile that far into an
area like you know the destination like
what happened that you know
but also it's like yeah you [ __ ] up so
either way there's no real excuse for it
you know you can't just like oops I
didn't intend guys I meant to kill those
other people those ukrainians I'm not
those you know the Polish people uh and
that's not a real great take to have to
be like I meant to kill these other
people not those other people so don't
don't hold it against me I didn't mean
to kill them
and it's it honestly is something
that you know it's either going to be
that one or someone's going to talk
about how like Russia has you know has a
very shitty
uh missile program or something like I'm
sure someone's gonna make some [ __ ]
dumb excuses be one of those two reasons
that somebody says oh well it wasn't
intentional they meant to shoot it this
way and they overshot it or they meant
to shoot this people and the rocket was
faulty because historically those their
missiles and Rockets are are
malfunctioning it's like neither excuse
does it justice
and you have to fuel it to make it that
far and if it is one of their solid
rocket propellant rockets that they
maintained it has one they have
uh an Armory you know to choose from and
they chose the [ __ ] rocket that could
make it right I mean because they have
very different grades of rock we don't
know which rock what type of Rocket it
was so I can't tell you if it was a
fueling issue or whatever but you know
it was [ __ ] because it's just like
driving your car you know Gabe if you're
gonna drive from from coast to coast
you're going to put x amount of gas in
your car you're going to budget x amount
of money for fuel shangling with a
rocket if it's going to make it to
[ __ ] Poland from Russia right they
fueled that [ __ ] bird to make it that
far I mean you have people you have
little rocket scientists who you know
they're studying the physics and the
chemistry of you know what goes into it
so for someone to go oopsie you know
like I made a mistake like oh you know
what I didn't have my cup of coffee
today so I missed it by a decimal point
no that doesn't happen because they're
not one you're not doing it by my by
hand but also you've got you've also got
computer software that's also it's not
just like shoot the missile and there it
goes like you're are tracking this thing
along the way at any point you could
perceivably shut it down if it goes too
far or you could
you know do something else to try to to
try to cancel it but
when you're like yep shoot it off and it
gets a certain point and you're like
he's got to keep it's like [ __ ] you
know the little engine I could like just
gotta keep truck and keep going keep
going and they're like okay well it hit
the destination that we intended to hit
as either a warning or kind of some sort
of like uh don't [ __ ] with us we this
looks like a piece of the rocket I don't
know yeah that's the photo I saw on
Twitter posting some I'm not sure of
this yet um again
um I'm trying to find if there's an
official even from our government I
haven't found one yet
um I would imagine that they're waiting
on Poland to see if well the article the
article that I've read so far basically
says uh the reasons for this event are
not known at this moment in an interview
with radio Lubin the spokesperson of the
district headquarters of the State Fire
Service in this town senior Captain
Marcin Leibowitz uh we received a report
the explosion on the dine yard or in the
drying yard in fact upon arrival we
confirm that something like that
happened two people died in the spot at
this moment we are securing the scene
and lighting the action
uh area or lighting the action area uh
we don't know what happened here is
secured and due to the Christ situation
the Prime Minister the con in
consultation with the president called a
meeting with the National Security
Bureau
um and then that's all they have really
well here Jason Jason J smart here has a
breaking two straight Rockets fell in
town in Poland uh two straight Rockets
now yeah it's two and two people died
um yes uh it and it says a Polish prime
minister convenes an urgent meeting of
the Council of ministers for National
Security so um if that is true then they
probably are talking uh Article Five
which article five Texas Paul my my my
take is on Article Five is is if Article
5 is invoked it's over for Putin I mean
he's [ __ ] finished here yeah let me
put it in terms that Q people can
understand where we go one we go all
that's article [ __ ] five right you
know so but it really does Poland's not
in the clear war in Russia Russia's
[ __ ] losing this yeah it's going to
Drudge out but now I don't I don't see
this they have done an amazing job and
what Russia is trying to do is provoke a
reaction and even if it's a shitty old
scut even it's like they're they're
shittiest old Rockets you gotta pick the
one that'll [ __ ] make it
you know what I mean this was not an
accident
I'm trying to see if they've got a map
but they I don't think that intelligence
is out there like how far and where this
came from like which direction it came
from
um still unclear but there apparently
there is two rockets they have confirmed
uh two missiles
um crossed over the Poland border and
has struck and killed two people which
the fact that they struck is one thing
the fact that they killed two
individuals is a whole nother [ __ ]
ball game here for this article five
um you don't just like you're saying
Paul you don't just sling sling
um bombs and Rockets across the border
especially when you're in a hot War
um with someone who's trying to receive
a NATO protection and you toss it into a
NATO Country Now where Article Five can
be invoked
um do you think this might be a do you
think this might be a cry because I
think you you kind of brought this you
know to that point earlier years is
maybe this is Putin wanting to end this
and he he doesn't want to end it himself
he wants someone to end it for him right
like he wants he he wants the yeah
that's it for him in other words he is
desperate to get these talks to include
more than Ukraine and Russia because
Ukraine has been very clear about their
position get the [ __ ] out of our country
and pay us back for the damage you did
that's our only offer [ __ ] you and Putin
is desperate to get somebody else
involved in this situation to get more
people at the table to talk because
China will not proxy for them I mean
they're just Putin's Putin's [ __ ]
himself he has and this war will be over
in a year I mean it's going to be that
long it's gonna it's gonna drag out but
Putin's military is broken
I mean it is broken his economy is
broken he is desperate to get out of
this with some some face saved and if he
can say I can escalate this boys
you better give me something
somebody somewhere is going to be
willing to be weak and say yeah we
probably should we should probably make
an offer hey you got Republicans here
that are telling us that you're going to
drag us into World War III Joe Biden
you're going to drag us into World War
III which is [ __ ] Joe Biden I
guarantee you Poland's not going to do a
[ __ ] thing without calling the White
House I mean they're an independent
country but you know in Article 5
only you know who's going to react
that have a military dripping and ready
to go I mean you know
yeah you've I mean you had to remember
you had people like Margaret Taylor
green on on the campaign Trail who were
pushing when we get control of the house
and we get control of the Senate what
we're gonna do is we're gonna stop any
payments and any Aid going to Ukraine
we're going to help the Russians right
you've got a party that is pro-putin
that is pro-genocide that is pro-killing
innocent people
innocent children mothers people in
hospitals they are pro destruction of a
country because they say well it's next
door Putin actually owns it he should
have it like we're gonna simp to Putin
and all this [ __ ] and we're going to
make sure that Putin is able to recover
we're gonna you know we're gonna lift
these
um
these restrictions on him we're gonna do
this we're gonna allow the flow of money
to come back into Russia we're gonna you
know we're gonna remove these sanctions
that is what the Republican party wants
they you've seen it from the get-go
instead of being like oh man we really
do sympathize and empathize with with
the human condition that is the
ukrainians being killed they go now [ __ ]
them we need to stop giving them money
right we need to stop funding this war
and I I guarantee if there was ever
another country that just like
inadvertently tried to or you know
purposely tried to attack and invade
Russia
these people be like you got to give
Putin all the money you got to give
Putin all the resources
um it's I'm looking for an official
statement from our government and I
don't see it yet
um President Biden has not released
anything the White House has not
released anything so my guess is they're
in these joint talks probably as we
speak I'm sure they're going to be in
like a war room situation
Anthony blinken is a smart capable
[ __ ] and I guarantee you he is
on this and you won't hear a peep out of
the state department until
they know all the facts and and have
already made an assessment of what
they're going to do I mean these I I am
so impressed with the Biden
Administration and the way they handle
things you know I I was raging mad when
Russia invaded Ukraine I was like we
need to kick those [ __ ] ass man
we need to I was like honey I'm going to
Ukraine you know I mean it was just I
was nuts when they first invaded
here's Anthony blinken's statement
within the last two hours if you want to
if you want to know sorry I don't mean
to step on it I just want to make sure
that we get this uh out here zielinski
demonstrated leadership again today by
making clear he is prepared for a
diplomacy towards a just end of the war
Russia started Russia's response was
another wave of missiles these attacks
will not break Ukraine's will we will be
with Ukraine for as long as it takes so
there is there is secretary blinken
um just hours
um not not even two hours because
apparently this happened within the last
Tower is when this happened and he
posted this on Twitter secretary Anthony
blinken posted this uh just just right
under two hours ago so this was just
before this strike or just right when
the strike was happening is when Anthony
blinken actually posted this so this is
the this is the
um the the most recent statement I can
see from a government official about
Russia or Ukraine uh to be that I can
find at this point so sorry Texas Paul I
didn't mean to step on you just want to
no you didn't I was just about to to to
to back up what Gabe's saying there you
know how [ __ ] stupid the the point of
view out of Russian or pardon me
Republicans are about Russia in the
Ukraine and how they this is a Russian
area and they ought to go back
Baja California is full of American
[ __ ] expats Cabo is not a Mexican
Town anymore man [ __ ] Sammy Hagar
owns more real estate and goddamn Cabo
than most than any Mexican does I'm
telling you man I am telling you that
would be like us saying you know what
that's ours now yeah we own that Baja's
ours it's just part of California now
you know
that's that [ __ ] insane they're
carving off the Eastern portion of
Ukraine and saying well we've got some
Russians that live there so yeah it's
Russia you [ __ ] [ __ ] you know yeah I
don't give a damn dude you cannot walk
into a country and just say
nah it's ours hell we invaded Iraq and
it's still [ __ ] Iraq right you know I
mean we didn't just take it you know
come on people
let's stop being stupid the the
proximity argument is one of the dumbest
ones out there I mean it's you know it
very much is like that or like a
Neighbor Next Door not you know well I
think here think of think of it like
this Rand Paul Republican uh probably
[ __ ] his neighbor over and tried to
you know trim the hedges or plant some
flowers on his side and the neighbor was
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] this is my property
this is the property line here you do
not and you cannot come over and do
whatever you want and that's probably
honestly why Rand Paul's neighbor did
that but think of it like that think of
Rand Paul who is obviously a Russian
simp and think of Rand Paul's neighbor
as Ukraine and zielinski and that
is a great way to look at that situation
he's trying to escalate to escalates it
escalates they yell back and forth
there's fights that ensue at the defense
line and then eventually you just kind
of kick his ass that's what you got to
do it looks like it looks like here
though that we are
um we are headed for Article Five though
I'm not gonna lie
um it it definitely seems as if
um the reporting if there's because
you don't accidentally send two rockets
yeah um across the border but I'm gonna
call I'm gonna call her right now this
[ __ ] show that's happening right before
us right now and you know 11 A.M uh uh 2
p.m Eastern is going to be a talking
point tonight during his announcement
Donald Trump announces he becomes he
wants to run for president again he's
going to talk about his crime inflation
all this [ __ ] [ __ ] he's going to
bring up my documents they took my
document yeah he's gonna took my
documents those stuff he's gonna bring
up this thing he's gonna be like you
know what would never happen this war
this would never happen if I was
president and of course of course
Republicans that are super magical like
yeah yeah yeah it'll be interesting to
see how Republicans react to this
rhetoric tomorrow morning
either they just completely skim over it
and they don't even talk about it like
they skimmed over him admitting to
sending the FBI and U.S attorneys down
to Florida to help Rhonda Sanders and
Rick Scott during the 2018 election
so I really do believe that he's going
to bring he will use that he will
politicize that to his own benefit and
talk about how if he was President this
wouldn't be a thing because Donald Trump
or uh Putin would do what he said and
blah blah blah is [ __ ] [ __ ] even
though we know it's not true well fellas
I appreciate uh I appreciate text Paul I
appreciate you Kevin sorry we we stepped
on the last 20 minutes there with the
breaking news but that happens uh I want
to bring this up here bno news has this
uh kind of the step through a village
near Ukraine explosions in a farm in a
rural area two people died at the scene
possibly caused by missiles that's
plural it looks like they're reporting
two missiles at this point uh government
uh calls emergency meeting that's Poland
Poland is a NATO member State that's uh
where the Article Five can be invoked
um and this was about 18 so just under
20 minutes ago no word yet from the
government and I'm I'm guessing b o is
talking about the Polish government
right there so everyone keep an eye on
this story we'll do a little more on
this tomorrow as we learn and we'll also
talk tomorrow about the Cheeto dust q
and honors great announcement tonight
I'm sure it'll be huge he better [ __ ]
run that [ __ ] [ __ ] um so everyone's
same time same place tomorrow as always
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific right
here on YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the minus the Facebook
page and our Facebook page Texas Paul
thanks for joining us go check out Texas
balls Channel as well the link is down
in the description if you're on YouTube
now to Texas Falls channel so go check
out Texas balls uh Channel over on
YouTube he does a couple shows every
week go check those out and make sure to
subscribe to his channel subscribe to
our Channel too
next week next week I'll I'll get you on
the flippy flip in your flippity flop
flip on the um on the uh on the slim jim
Taco thing what how is it how is it they
got something there see okay
you [ __ ] yeah well that's just
that's a tortilla in meat now he had the
[ __ ] string cheese on there [ __ ] hey
easy the cheese whiz is gonna make it
it's gonna make it gold everyone same
time same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
foreign